hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey happy Sunday to you
we're gonna celebrate this Sunday with a
Mortal Kombat 11 trailer reaction blood
and gore I should have said that now
we're gonna get those highly warranted
yellow dollar bill signs altercations
and disputes settled in a physical
environment I love the way YouTube does
the yellow dollar bill signs because
they they have some like automated thing
where something goes off and they go
nope nope new yellow dollar bill sign
and then nine times out of ten when you
request a review after the video is done
gathering all its views then they let
the yellow dollar bill sign go is not
about contest just about the appearance
of certain words and ideas although to
be fair Mortal Kombat's pretty violent
this is true this is just for you guys
let's just keep this one raw no cuts
let's just have some fun here shall we
oh I'm excited ever since we're not
cutting let's let's kill time while this
video is downloading I heard this
trailer is much just because I got some
comments to the it's Tyrone talked about
a very old reaction I did for this one
the all brutality is one because like
the most popular video on the channel I
have to leave the room
it's the robe all in the camera I didn't
like it was very like very little like I
felt very nauseous and it's really a
little bit just you know sues to eat
really bad and smoke cigarettes I've
been so let's check this out
nice looks even better yeah okay rap
music y-yeah let go dark right it looks
nice I get backups you survive 1100
[Music]
the writings got a full dark fatality
whoa Wow Wow let's cool scorpion there
huh those dopes
yeah I gotta tell you guys Shao Kahn is
the best video game adaptation movie
villain ever in Mortal Kombat
annihilation haha just putting that out
there
oh yeah yeah I don't I don't mean that
sir Castle you don't I forgot how much I
love watching Mortal Kombat cutscenes
and these fight sequences bone-crunching
gore and violence
exactly it's the exact same thing it's
just better graphics yeah gets a little
more you know sleek and ingenuity filled
good you know I've never played the
games for the storyline there's actually
this is well I I bought this game I used
to live next to Tony and I remember he
got an Xbox one and then Mortal Kombat X
came out and he couldn't afford at the
time and because I live directly on the
other side of him I just bought it and
we played it we used to play that we
played the other one all the time and I
sucked it I suck at this game I do I
liked like Tekken I'm good at but Mortal
Kombat III awful I love play to play for
hours oh yeah as part of the fun is
watching bones crunch and yes pray out
and I don't I just suck at getting to
the feet I like doing the right button
[Music]
stop punching
but now there's the stuff that always
really gets me or the more raw like when
he breaks the finger that's ridiculous
well I mean I was flashing back to that
one video they did where they kept
having the like x-rays of everything
that you were breaking yeah destroying
but even in the environments to look
pretty cool I mean yeah the biggest
thing I took out of this is just how
real it all comes across how its art
ride is here man yeah so badass well
this is a cinematic you know depiction
of the game like it's pretty beautiful
to look at you know the rap music is an
interesting choice yeah yeah mostly just
because I guess it works
tone of that song just felt kind of
laid-back yeah for the carnage on screen
that's cool that's cool yeah random part
of this trip I'll just throw a song over
it whatever you want yeah yeah I'm tired
of heavy metal find something dude
that's like what you'd expect in a video
game adaptation movie yeah video game
itself
I like that weird thing we're like video
games are kind of heavy metal but movies
are more hip-hop yeah that's an
interesting choice there but hey I had a
great time watching you know who's gonna
have a fun time playing this is JT or
man from Hawaii I do in JT I heard you
had a good Thanksgiving with your
abusive father and your neglectful
mother I'm sorry that you have to deal
with that but you're in Hawaii where you
can you know do all kinds of
recreational activities to help you
chill out you recommended a lot of anime
shows for us lately to go watch out our
patreon I appreciate that you know
you're always looking out for us and
you're always very kind and I really
love that about you you know I've
actually had a pretty killer year on
movie fights and I gotta admit that the
first time I want on movie fights we had
a long ass discussion with JT before we
ever did it so you my friend are a big
part of what has led to the growth of
the channel my success on movie fights
so I really applaud you and what I
recommend is I know your dad is a former
cop maybe break into his room take his
weapon do a little riding on him you
know I mean yeah yeah yeah come on us
and this job get over here dad and then
you know you'll feel finish him and
you'll do some kind of awesome come I
like I feel like I got like a what yes
and this without being like yeah just
steal your dad's gun and go shoot him
hello John now we definitely have a
yellow dollar oh that's what I didn't
want I was trying to avoid words like
weed and gun murder and violence and
damn it's disturbing that's a that's a
yellow dollar but I just want to cuddle
with JT man
want to do the violent thing you know JT
is such a warm wonderful presence and I
don't want to corrupt his mind man he's
got ideas in there why do you think that
every time we chat with JT it's ID a day
you know we should just put a black
screen for the next two minutes so we
hit that ten-minute mark yeah yeah
people love that and just you know I'm
still ringing the sound yeah well I did
early we're not a gaming channel we're
just check this out because now Google
requested this but speaking of gaming
my brother just got me spider-man ps4
which is totally the same kind of
audience for Mortal Kombat guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check us on
patreon we got TV show reaction watch so
long as a music video coverage from John
I occasionally guests are on that and
weekly q and A's as well we're actually
gonna go shoot one right now oh man if
we just put that black straight on there
for 40 more seconds we might we could
hit that 10-minute mark
let's just be no no they know what we're
gonna be fair we're just gonna wait
toward the 9 minute and 59 second marked
and not be [ __ ] and throw a mid roll
out of here for you guys
this is right when we're at the 9 minute
and 50 we have 5 seconds of our logo at
the end so once around 9 minute and 54
seconds okay we're gonna stop this